у нас те слово я за минулий модератора
казкові культури
френку наталія Сергєєва запущено нове
слово
через провадження своїх
ворожий і намагаєшся на пропустити
та моїх колег у 4 iv по дорозі
види та форми для реалізації початкових у
здорових вихлопних газів до нас правді
змусили і вимагатиме ви бог їх змін
кардинальних змін ще на сьогодні ми
пропадаємо їх качанів і школі на сьогодні
польша класно як ми про панораму дати
загальних теоретичних знань на вигляд
фізичної культури
так і ще нами але ми не здаєте у профі
сильних спортсменів повз устілки
ти арі
кишені нова фізичного розвитку та
всіх ти притча їм до куман клас струн
як рок помру чекають їхнього богота
клас david 100 ват і на секунду мером
руках з початкова школа у нас
мене звуть син ми на мага і ми одразу ось
хіба вати в школі помалювати чули ми
по помилці в промовах їх ніж у дітей, але сад
і лижі на правому плечі спочатку потим
наліво ми плачемо раз уват осі z в
українці до преважно пишеш кіл на
гроші не маю змогу придбати сорок пар
лиж 40 парбат ось і навіки ви красуються
тильки підібгати кави та школі ideco ти сюди
засніжена зима
впорайтеся тому я всім і кожним ще б
ти інтерес від матикина б ти інтерес
з природознавства ми на що приховуємо
інтерес з фізичної культури
ти ми можемо розроблена тільки зміни а
можемо побачити дати й послугу занепалого
ти про світло і задувало ним дітям, як він
його ти там життя в праві та різанини та
гри позики за програмою у
хто у нас проти чити роману йому розділи
програму з на монтаж ним three good in
in a також немає дати дві гадини піт
інваріант не взуття скоби модулі
які ми включаємо у активного чоловіка
поздоровлення гімнастика замовленнях вона фізична
на підготовка ми їх у нову йому ми їх
там організовуємо а от ну от і але вид
виступить варіативний модуль за божа
німцем уже б ти хореографії може і
плавання на хортинг розрулюються
програми і тут далі їм можна весь
дозволяє дозволяю розробити програму
за рукава ним на регіональних яки
христа масу начхати ти а так вже
завертай china увагу забезпечення школи
матеріально-технічної бази за
забезпечення квалі століття ванними
фахівцям ці їй школи я хочу мене
нім фахівця скоро і графітом
анімашку в 4
фізкультури ну давай йому завдання
начальник рок та дітям давати з policies
головку вин борщ even розрубані
вельможі тип кец роботи йоржи там у я все
ми про панама танцювальних руки так
багата на пропозиції було ви краще ти
плавання ви краще ти лижі ви краще ти
танцювальне коло її до чого вдома туди
увійти мій варять іншому модулю на даємо йому
шви вести дітям та танцювальних руки
замінна ритмічну а еротику
але так c est з вас жахлива програма
with cum on 3 дні стику те як вона не
обов'язковий консервант їх руки володію
мытую за дикуватий дітей я